then we can all keep chatting together
perhaps in perpetuity
and when I say in perpetuity I mean
perpetuity I mean forever because
according to Ray Kurzweil
we are on the brink of immortality
there's an old clip resurfix saying from
a documentary about Ray Kurzweil Ray
Kurzweil is a computer scientist and
he's
much respected in Silicon Valley and has
been for decades now and Ray Kurzweil
has predicted
that within about eight or so years
mankind will achieve
in this world
eternal life
Kurzweil says revolutions and genetics
nanotechnology and Robotics will Usher
in the beginning of the singularity
kurzwill feels with sufficient genetic
technology it should be possible to
maintain the body indefinitely reversing
aging while curing cancer heart disease
and other illnesses Kurzweil envisions
Nanobots which allow people to eat
whatever they want while remaining thin
and fit provide copious energy fight off
infections or cancer replace organs and
augment their brains eventually people's
bodies will contain so much augmentation
they'll be able to alter their physical
manifestation at will Kurzweil writes
that by 2010 a supercomputer will have
the computational capacity to emulate
human intelligence and by around 2020
this same capacity will be available for
one thousand dollars after that
Milestone he expects human brain
scanning to contribute to an effective
model of human intelligence by the
mid-2020s these two elements will
culminate in computers that can pass the
Turing test by 2029 by the early 2030
the amount of non-biological computation
will exceed the capacity of all living
biological human intelligence
so this is not a new documentary this is
obviously not a new prediction raker as
well as made all sorts of predictions
over the years and you might say this is
totally far-fetched and then you just
start hearing some of his predictions
say well he did say did kind of predict
when AI would start to really develop in
any kind of predicted all almost
perfectly when AI would really start to
take off and he's made a lot of other
predictions too according to
rakersweil and his supporters
out of the 147
discrete predictions he has made about
technology and Humanity in the future 86
percent of them
have come true
so are we going to live forever here on
Earth
I don't believe it I I don't quite
believe it 86 percent right means that
you were wrong 14 of the time I'm no
mathematician but that's I think how the
numbers work out and
here's why I think that
here are some of the other predictions
reiker's wild has made he accurately
predicted that consumers will be able to
design their own clothes with precise
measurements and style requirements from
home computers by 1999.
and that that happened
the world's best chess player would lose
to a computer by 2000 that happened deep
blue totally destroyed Kasparov with
facts and logic
that people would primarily use portable
computers in a wide range of sizes and
shapes by 2009 2009 Maps almost exactly
with the development of the iPhone here
we go I got this one over here we have
all sorts of supercomputers yep little
miniature miniature computers rather and
the majority of the world would have
high bandwidth wireless internet access
at all times by 2010 seems to have
basically come true
all of those predictions are rather
Limited in scope though
those are the kinds of predictions that
futurists and technology-minded people
have accurately made
for centuries now
the immortality prediction is something
that
power mad Fallen humans have have
predicted and sought after
since the dawn of time
since
since the earliest mythical conceptions
of humanity we have sought after that
and I don't I don't see it happening
just as Adam and Eve in the Garden of
Eden might have reached for that tree of
the knowledge well they did reach for
the fruit of the tree of the knowledge
of Good and Evil they might have reached
for the tree of life and they were
booted out of the garden just as
the ancient Babylonians were building up
that Tower of Babel they were just about
to reach heaven and then they were all
scattered I just don't think we get
there I think that
human beings
even if we're even if we're blundering
into that sort of thing we we will be
protected for our own good by our own
incompetence and I just
I just don't buy it I think these are
people who could have eternal life if
they wanted it they just got to say the
word they're not going to do it through
their own efforts and their own
computers Elon Musk
has just signed a statement
with Wozniak from Apple
with a lot of top computer scientists
and AI Developers
urging a six-month moratorium on the
development of AI
I signed up yesterday for one of the
fancy AI programs where you have to pay
like 10 bucks a month to to be able to
try it out and I did it because I heard
that these fancier AI programs were much
much much more impressive than the
freebies that everybody gets to try out
and so I thought all right I want to see
how good this stuff really is
it's unbelievable the artwork that it
can produce the
compositions that these programs can
produce it is unbelievable a lot of
people thought that AI might be useful
for calculations for
some aspects of business but the one
thing they could never do is create art
or poetry that's something that only
humans can do and what do we find out
the thing that AI is best at perhaps is
Art and poetry so we just don't really
know what this thing is and how
how far it's going to go and how quickly
it's going to go that far so what Elon
and the other people have suggested is
quote such decisions
about the development of AI must not be
delegated to unelected Tech leaders
powerful AI systems should be developed
only once we're confident that their
effects will be positive and their risks
will be manageable this confidence must
be well Justified this is of course true
and you might hear some people insist I
either on the left or on the right
insist that no we can't have the
government limit creativity that's
probably what you hear from the left or
you might hear her from the right you
can't have the government stop the
progress of the free market or whatever
but
AI is potentially very very dangerous
AI will almost certainly transform our
society in ways that we haven't seen
certainly since the development of the
internet maybe since the development of
industrialization maybe since the
development of who knows
and so the point that Elon is making and
Wozniak and the rest of the compsi guys
is is not even a point about AI
it's a point about politics
whatever happens with AI
a development at this scale
is a political matter
in recent decades our conception of
politics has become really really
shallow and narrow
on the left the the leftists have said
Paul keep your politics out of my
bedroom keep your politics out of my
drug bin keep your politics out of
whatever I want to do socially and on
the right the conservatives have said
keep your politics out of my business
keep your politics out of my bank
account keep your politics out of my
personal life but politics is just what
we do together politics just means
public
and and the
the conception of politics at the
founding of our country was a much more
robust conception the whole idea of
self-government is that we're going to
be really involved in politics and we're
going to come to conclusions about the
world and how we want to live and then
we're going to impose them on the
society through our through our vote and
through our elected representatives
could you imagine if the nuclear bomb
were being developed
just after it was developed and then
the nuclear bomb were strictly A Private
Matter
so keep your politics out of my business
man we're building a bomb no of course
not it's a highly political matter and
people have the right to put some
limitations on it the fact that
we haven't seen nuclear weapons used in
war since World War II is very
impressive and it attests to the ability
of political action to keep a handle on
things in society I think I think Elon
is totally right I'm still miffed that
I'm not on Twitter right now so Elon
please take put me back on Twitter and
don't boot me off of The Social Network
for quoting the Bible but he's
absolutely right about about AI we've
got a lot more coming up in the member
block
got a lot on AI producer Jacob has taken
over the show today we'll see how he
does head on over to the Knowles
treadamus member room segmentum
dailywire.com Knowles promo code knows a
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]